There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
to test for ourselves.
I finally got my hands on
the Haus Labs Atomic Shake lip lacquer.
This is another one of
those transfer-proof
glossy lipsticks.
This is definitely the
hot new lip formula.
So, you shake the product
well, then apply it.
The pigment in this really shocked me.
It was so vibrant, it almost looked neon.
This went on so smooth,
I didn't need more than one
layer for full coverage,
and it was so glossy.
I had to wait 15 seconds
for what they call the
"shine shield" to form.
Then I kissed the back of my hand
to see if I got any transfer, and nothing.
I've tried three lipsticks
with this kind of formula,
and so far, this is the best one.
This is the Modelones Color
Cube in Bonfire Amour.
It's a solid gel cream palette.
It comes with nine gel polishes,
and you can get them in
different color stories
and finishes.
It also comes with this little brush.
I've used a solid gel cream before,
but I forgot how thick it actually is,
so it did take me some time
to apply it in even layers.
I did have to do two coats
for full coverage on some colors.
I think a product like this
can be super convenient,
especially if you do nail art
or just don't have the space
to keep a bunch of gel polishes around.
It doesn't come with a base or topcoat,
but I still really like this.
I tested out a ton of
products from Jason Wu Beauty.
This is a new brand for me,
so let's start with what I didn't like.
This Free-Da Brow was too light
for me, which is my fault,
but the formula on this is weird.
It feels like an oily cream
that never dries down,
so I doubt it'll keep my brows in place.
These Stay in Line lip
liners weren't great.
They were also too light for me,
so I ended up using my own
lip liner to deepen it.
These are smooth but a little too creamy.
They don't feel like they're going to
last very long on the lips at all.
I also didn't like the Wu-Prime Eye.
The formula is so tacky and thick.
It made my eye shadow look
patchy in certain areas.
Now on to the stuff I loved.
This Flora 4 palette was
surprisingly pigmented
and easy to blend.
I feel like the primer
is what got in the way
of showing you its full potential,
but I still really liked it.
This blush trio is so gorgeous
and blended out really nicely.
I used this Ready to Shimmer
cream shadow as a highlighter,
and it gave me the prettiest golden glow,
even though it's not
really meant for the face.
This Jewel Stick was incredible.
Look how much it brightened
up my inner corners.
The Honey Fluff lip cream
was soft and comfortable on the lips.
If you get anything from this brand,
get this Extra Pout lip plumper.
Oh, my God. Even if you don't care
about the lip-plumping aspect,
this is one of the best lip-gloss formulas
I have ever tried.
It's so cushiony and shiny and amazing,
and everyone should get it.
The Make Up For Ever The
Professionall Mascara
is ... definitely a mascara.
It's nothing amazing.
It has one side for lifting
and the other side for volumizing.
I didn't get much of a lift,
but I did get a nice amount of volume.
I just think there are
better mascaras out there
for way less money.
I am a huge fan of About-Face.
I love so many of its products.
So when these Cheek Freak
blush balms dropped,
I snatched up three different colors.
I'm just gonna say it.
I am so in love with these.
I was nervous at first
because it's described as a "blush balm,"
which to me sounded like it
would break up my foundation,
but these blended in so beautifully.
It never moved the product underneath,
even if my skin was already powdered,
and the pigment on these is unreal.
You can build them up
however much you want.
I think these can work for
so many different skin tones.
They are so, so good.
I made the horrible mistake of purchasing
the Winky Lux Saucy Gloss
four-piece combo lip-gloss set.
This was made in
collaboration with Applebee's,
and the glosses are
inspired by its wing sauces.
You guys, I thought
everyone was exaggerating
when they said the smell
was making them gag, but no.
These smell God-awful, and it sucks so bad
because the color story is so pretty.
And I could see this concept working
had they just not added the sauce scents,
or even if they did something like,
lemon pepper smells like lemon,
Buffalo is just a spicy lip plumper.
But no, they went in this direction.
We all bought it and talked about it,
which is probably what they wanted.
So I hope you're happy, Winky Lux.
You ruined four beautiful glosses.
I tried out a new foundation from Chanel.
I actually wouldn't
call this a foundation.
It's more like a
super-hydrating, light tint.
It's very similar to that
Rose Inc tinted serum
I tried a while ago.
So it has these pigment beads that burst
and spread as you apply it.
This literally feels
like nothing on the skin.
There is little coverage,
but it evens everything out
nicely and it feels hydrating.
I don't think this has
a strong staying power,
but it's still a pretty tint
for when you don't want to do too much.
Chanel also has a blush in this formula,
so I tested that out too.
I actually blended it out
on the back of my hand
before applying and tapped
it on with a sponge.
It took a minute to build up the color,
but I think it's supposed
to look very natural.
It also didn't break up
the product underneath.
I'm surprised by how much I liked these.
They don't do too much,
but it's enough to make a difference.
This is the Maybelline Shadow
Blocks Eyeshadow Palette.
It's a tiny stack of eye shadows,
very similar to the Kaja bento trios.
The packaging is pretty cheap.
One of my shadows fell out, but it's OK.
I applied these without any primer
just to see how they perform on their own.
They're actually pretty pigmented shadows.
I didn't have any trouble blending them,
and the shimmer shade was pretty,
but overall I think these are just OK.
I like the idea of a palette like this
more than the execution.
Everyone has been loving
these NYX Jumbo Lash lashes,
so I had to try them
even though I am terrible
with false lashes.
I thought the style Ego Flare
would look nice on my eye
shape, and I was right.
These lashes made me feel
like a whole new person.
Like, these are Disney princess eyes.
They were pretty easy to apply,
and the band was really comfortable.
I think these have totally convinced me
to wear lashes more often.
This is the Urban Decay
24/7 Moondust Shadow
in Space Cowboy.
This is basically a glitter shadow.
This shade in particular
has been going viral.
It is super intense and reflective,
but you can definitely
diffuse it to be more subtle.
This formula is really
smooth and easy to work with
however you want to use
it, so I really loved this.
I did get some glitter fallout,
so I'd recommend using a primer
or leaving some powder under
the eyes while you're applying.
If you want something more eye-catching
and elevated than a shimmer
shadow, this is perfect.